sarah palin is running for congress
sarah palin is the for our younger
viewers she was a sort of precursor to
the trump types this is this is actually
a really interesting political history
moment
bush george w bush was kind of dim and
uh
the thing about him is he's not really
all of it led to trump but he's not
really the pre-trump mold in the sense
that he was actually a neocon bush was a
neocon
palin was kind of the first what i call
sort of like uh
dumacon where it's like you're the main
thing is you don't know anything with
bush he didn't know much but he was
still a neocon at heart
palin was the first sliver of what
eventually was trump and trumpism which
is they're just clueless reactionaries
lacking any real ideology and she was uh
the late john mccain's running mate in
2008 they fortunately lost to barack
obama and she is now running for
congress sarah palin files to run for
the late alaska representative don
young's seat
sarah palin filed with the fec on friday
for the special election she said
america is at a tipping point as i've
watched the far left destroy the country
i knew i had to step up and join the
fight
palin filed an hour before friday's
filing let deadline there are 50
candidates in the field so for the we'll
have plenty of time to talk about sarah
palin more
but for those who maybe don't remember
her
she was known for the word salad before
trump perfected it here's one example
from an interview in 2016 with jake
tapper uh a visibly disoriented sarah
palin here
you talked about inconsistencies among
the votes and the positions of senator
cruz donald trump is somebody who has
clearly had uh different positions on
issues that he has today including an
issue very near and dear to your heart
the issue of abortion and life right uh
have you talked to him about that he
used to be he called himself very
pro-choice now he says he's very
pro-life i am so glad that mr trump has
seen the light and understands the the
sanctity of innocent life and how um a
baby in the womb it should be most
protected what has been kind of sad
about the situation though politically
speaking are groups that are pro-life
and want to they say they want to bring
more people into the fold they given
trump a hard time for his past views on
abortion where they're celebrating
others like um i was going through a
list
like justin bieber
what
and um
gosh
yeah yeah who who has made
that that this is jake tapper's best
moment where he looks perplexed and goes
justin bieber
yeah we i don't know either uh jake it's
understanding the the sanctity of life
but in the past he said he was no big
deal to him you know
he's just one example but i've heard
these same groups celebrate people who
have i've been to their fundraisers i've
spoken at their events and there's
usually someone in the crowd every
single one of these crowds who'll
testify to having seen the light you
know to understand oh i yeah so i'm
really hoping that she does some debates
uh here's one more example again for our
young viewers
here is sarah palin speaking at a trump
event and really just
an incredible word salad immigrants
welcoming this is like a chop chop
they've really chopped it all up and
it's just like confetti them in even
inducing and seducing them with gift
baskets come on over the border and
here's a basket of teddy bears and
soccer balls our kids and our grandkids
they'll never know then
what it is to be rewarded for that
entrepreneurial spirit that god creates
within us
in order to work and to produce and to
strive and to thrive and to really be
alive wisconsin
reagan saved the hog
here
you're harley davidson that was reagan
it made as little sense then as it does
now and we can only hope that sarah
palin will be participating in debates
so sarah palin is running another
notable race in 2020 much ahead when it
comes to the midterms
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video